where is she she said she'd be here at
midnight exactly she tries to scare
I hate you
I really hate you take you through
twists and turns into places you never
wanted to go
scary movie night part 2 welcome back to
stuckman scary movie night that's part 2
or stuckman scary movie special whatever
you want to call it we're back here
talking about scary movies we both
really appreciate the really nice
response that we've gotten from the part
1 what you thinking a little intro I
wonder if some of them got it it
probably helps me grow up in the 90s I
love are you afraid of the dark it was
one of my favorite television shows to
come home and watch at night it's a fun
cheesy 90s show a lot of the episodes
are still on YouTube and similar to
goosebumps which we talked about in the
last part it's one of those shows that
kind of helps if you grew up with it if
you watch it nowadays it does seem very
dated because it is dated you see all
the old 90 Styles like the backwards
baseball hats with their hair sticking
out through little through the hole in
the hat big baggy short jeans like jean
shorts the show is cheesy some weird of
goose bumps but it is still a lot of fun
and we wanted to do our own little
tribute to it recognizing are you afraid
of the dark
alright guys we're gonna lead into a
skit this time this is a film when it
came out in 1999 that had a response
that was generated largely because
people weren't entirely sure if this
movie was actually real or fake it was
one of the very first ever mockumentary
but a lot of people in 99 legitimately
thought it was real in fact if you read
Roger Ebert one of the greatest film
critics who ever lived his review had
uncertainty in it about if it was real
or not because it's the kind of film
that just starts and ends with no
credits or anything so we wanted to film
this skit and we made it look very
low-budget we did not use professional
sound equipment so the sound sounds
really bad in this but we did that on
purpose to make it seem kind of like the
original film so hopefully you enjoy our
skit
[Applause]
so how do you feel about being in
haunted woods of still Ohio yeah what
exactly would possess us to go into
these woods some stuff people left
behind I'm looking at your behind that's
what I'm doing now tell me what is this
a kids house or a swingset do you think
maybe the children sometimes still play
on the swings at night the dead children
you know what I think I think I'd like
to that's what I'd like to do
someone engraved their names the guy in
town said that John and Jenna were the
kids that were killed out here maybe or
maybe there's a witch out here that's
going to eat us and rip our heads off
and that's not even true no you're
beautiful let's just go look for that
witch
yes maybe hey I think I heard something
over there
yeah did you hear something yeah that's
nice how do you suppose these things got
launched into the wood yeah those things
up there they're like in the wood I
think it was something else because I'm
agent fucking Mulder you fucking fuck
this is basically what the Blair Witch
Project is like but it's awesome
well fuckity fuck fuck I don't know so
the Blair Witch Project is a movie that
nowadays some people don't like the film
they find it boring they feel it's
pointless and that's understandable
because nowadays there are so many found
footage films that you can kind of look
at it and think wow this isn't really
that great because nothing really
happens it's a lot of people walking
through the woods asking people
questions and their sounds and you know
it leads to a kind of strange finale but
where this film really shines is when it
came out and the response that people
had to it and the oddness of the whole
is it real is it not real thing I
remember watching it for the first time
being a little disturbed thinking this
actually has some possibility of being
real now it couldn't be maybe possibly
right no it's a very cheap way to make
films and they all tend to make money
and you can make found footage films for
such a small budget and Blair Witch
proved that that is extremely profitable
because the movie was made for like
nothing and it made skyrocketing amounts
of money the Blair Witch to me is just a
creepy movie and it feels right in
October because a lot of it's in the
woods the leaves are falling and you
really do kind of get in
the lives of these characters I really
got to give props to these actors
because they actually did a tremendous
job because there were many people who
legitimately thought they were watching
real footage when you watch this film
big does like make you jump and startle
in places if you haven't watched it
before if you have a night and you're
free and you just want to watch a film
it's kind of disposable but enjoyable
for this time of year check out Blair
Witch all right guys we're coming in
with another nostalgia piece this is
also from the 90s
it's called hocus pocus I know you can
laugh at us I actually had not seen this
film ever and she showed it to me for
the first time the other day because a
lot of kids feel that it's you know it's
kind of like a very as you said
nostalgic movie that you watch in the
90s you grew up with it you watch it you
have fun with it
you're kind of aware of the fact that
it's not really good I guess it's got
Bette Midler and Sarah Jessica Parker in
it and another actress whose name
escapes me at this time but Kathy
minimun ninja met with a bit bad back
Kathy okay but I gotta say watching the
movie for the first time as an adult
probably didn't really do it any favors
for me because the witches really got on
my nerves yeah I mean an adult watching
this film is not easy unless you kind of
put ear plugs in in a couple scenes but
the kids are entertaining you have to
give props to the little girl I'm
looking at the fact that this is in my
house no it's not it's not a part it's a
funny it's a fun childhood film it's a
fun childhood it is an iconic Disney
movie that I can't believe you never saw
the kids I saw this in school it's a fun
childhood film it's just that it wasn't
part of my childhood
the Lambs Clarice tell me more about the
Lambs
that's what I deal with on a daily basis
the Silence of the Lambs
Anthony Hopkins an iconic classic
performance one of the best performances
ever given by an actor in my opinion
Jodie Foster also oscar-winning
performance in the film it's a movie
that when you watch it it's not just the
performances that really suck you into
this movie this story is so dark and
very disturbing you got two great
villains in the movie one of them is
Buffalo Bill he locks girls down deep in
the holes that he digs in his house and
then he sucks his penis and between his
legs and dances and you don't get
creepier than that you just don't get
any creepier than that think you do the
name Buffalo Bell and his penis and it's
just it don't think don't think we got
too much so you got the really creepy
and disturbing Buffalo Bill but you also
have the cold and calculating smart
villain and Anthony Hopkins portrayal of
a Hannibal Lecter who's in jail for the
majority of the movie and yet he is so
medicine just by the fact that you know
this guy is behind bars or glass in this
movie and the best parts of this movie
are those conversations between him and
Jodie Foster's character and you get to
see Anthony Hopkins just shine so much
in this movie he he rarely ever actually
blinks in this movie he said I don't
want to blink hardly at all his Hannibal
Lecter it's very creepy because you
watch him and it's all his eyes like you
can't take your eyes off his performance
in that movie it's so well done it's a
very scary movie because unlike certain
films we have talked about that are just
fun movies you can watch this movie has
possibilities there are
serial killers out there there are
cannibals out there and certain parts of
this movie you feel like yeah this could
actually happen and so for that reason
it kind of gets under your skin we come
from a state where there was actually a
cannibal so that kind of hits home for
you then yeah yeah I can't believe you
don't remember Jeffrey Dahmer of course
not remember Jeffrey Dahmer me that was
always like oh my god we come from a
state where this actually has kinda
almost happened right with the Jeffrey
Dahmer story it's like it wasn't too far
from here either he was four actually
our area yeah kind of disturbing about
20 miles from here actually yeah let's
not talk about that sorry but I actually
got the surprise in my life and I picked
up this case and popped in the DVD and
didn't know what the film was I didn't
know what science and the Lambs was I
thought it maybe was just a cheesy
horror film and I was just saying
oh it's got to be good it's got a little
I thought it was a butterfly at the time
popped in the DVD I know my god I was
like I can t remember how old I was when
I was like oh why did I get this wife do
I get this blockbuster betrayed me
not about Lambs not about Mazda
butterflies at all there's hints of
those animals in the movie but you know
[Music]
the shock of my life I was young I
didn't know how to flip the cover over
and read it you couldn't flip over cover
no I could I just you want to mean by
when you're a little kid go by with the
covers I don't read sir
all right guys the next film on our list
is the kind of film that we have to talk
about if we didn't talk about this film
in this list we'd be dumb usually I say
if your favorite film is an inner list I
apologize sorry this is our list no this
this has to be discussed this movie has
to be on this list we hinted at it in
the finale of part 1 a little shot of it
in the beginning of this one too and I
hope you enjoy our skit of this classic
film
[Music]
yes Halloween is the film and we are
going to stop that otherwise we're never
going to get to this video because it
will be very distracting
Halloween directed by John Carpenter
came out in 1978 you watch this film now
in fact you and I literally did just
watch this today as a refresher and you
like our scenes a million times you know
there's a killer and there's a girl and
she's running and she falls and
everyone's stupid and all they had sex
they're gonna get killed we just talked
about scream and how scream Perry did
all of those things but in 1978 this
film shocked and terrified audiences
around the world and it was very
profitable it was made for hardly
anything at all and obviously became a
cultural phenomenon in regards to
slasher films in the 80s there were so
many of them and you can look at
Halloween and kind of blame it for that
negatively but I don't even really
consider too many of the Halloween
sequels at all I just enjoyed the first
one i watch it Michael Myers as a
villain really works still for me even
though I know it's a William Shatner
mask spray-painted white and it also
gave the world Jamie Lee Curtis and all
of her body's glory and I must say that
is a very nice addition she has a mature
face she does she has a mature and
that's where they think we watch the
movie you know like these these are not
eighteen-year-old high schoolers you
know that they're probably like 21 25 or
something but the movie just has this
great feel to it where it's the
low-budget charm combined with john
carpenter's awesome score and the way he
took a film that was actually supposed
to be originally conceived as just this
schlocky let's just do this killer movie
and get into theaters and see we can
make a quick buck John Carpenter got a
hold of that movie and he made it a lot
better than it could have been for that
reason Halloween has remained a mainstay
in the world of like a thing you have to
do every year around this time it's the
slasher film I say yes the cheesy ones
that came after it it's the slasher film
this could possibly happen there is
mental institutions there guy could
break out in the first movie it was just
this insane man who is viewed as the
personification of evil through Donald
Pleasance his performance which was very
good and he was kind of a name back in
the 70s and he added some legitimacy to
the movie and
kept it more grounded as an actor he did
a very good job in the movie like the
whole thing in this movie is that
Michael Myers is just evil he is evil
and everything about him is evil
right he's the boogeyman you know they
talked about him in that way in the
movie and it's kind of funny and silly
but this movie has like a deep
undercurrent of this message the evil
never dies
you can't kill evil it will always be
around no matter what the other sequels
made it all ghostly and revenge and
resurrection and this and that and it's
all crap but this movie is a classic
Halloween right well guys our next film
he's Nightmare on Elm Street and not the
remake no no no no he original directed
by Wes Craven came out in 1984 and
Nightmare on Elm Street is another one
of those movies where it came out in a
period where there were so much crap
slasher slasher everywhere and it's just
one of the ones that actually came out
that really was good and that's because
it took it in a different direction
Freddy is a killer that can only get you
in your sleep in your dreams so he can
be anywhere in your dreams I mean if I
had the chance to direct a movie like
that that would just spark any
filmmakers imagination yeah I can do
anything with this guy I can have him be
in any setting anywhere I can set up
anything creepy or scary that I think of
each dream a little bit different and
not just keep repetitively doing the
same thing where you're strangling the
person slashing the person and of course
we have another iconic villain that of
Freddy Krueger a man with the burned
face in the clawed hands what are you
doing and of course the classic score as
well it's awesome there's certain whore
thumbs from back in the day where you as
soon as you hear the music like yep I
know exactly what that is psycho is
Halloween nightmare no street is that
classic it's perfect like it just feels
like a dream the musical score evoked
that feeling I loved how the film was
able to do very clever scares as if the
dreams were coming into reality like
Freddy's hand coming out of the lather
while the girls in the bath I'm not a
woman but to me as I watched that I feel
invaded my privacy has been invaded cuz
she's saying that her legs I literally
spread open and you just see this hand
go
this time like you do take a lot of
baths I love me some baths I have to
remember growing up and there aids in
Elm Street not too far from here and I
always want to be walking past it going
I wonder yeah I've seen that street sign
Freddy Krueger lurking behind one of
these houses possibly so we've grown up
next to Jeffrey Dahmer and in Elm Street
we are kinda bad position all right guys
here's the movie I haven't seen so I'll
let Chris talk about this I have not
seen it we didn't get a chance to watch
this film we will in the future but we
watched like literally like 10 horror
movies in the past couple days but Shaun
of the Dead is a film that I think is
extremely special because it's a
combination of horror and comedy it's
the type of film that as you watch it
you are so blown away by the directorial
vision and it's part of the Cornetto
trilogy directed by Edgar Wright
starring Simon Pegg and Nick Frost
you got Hot Fuzz Shaun of the Dead and
the worlds and part of this unofficial
trilogy this was the very first one and
no wonder people were like wow this is a
serious talent and I'm looking forward
to showing it to you for the first time
because it's a very silly film but it
has such a great heart in it it's it's
more funny than safe screaming it
parodies the zombie genre and zombie
films in general but like there's a
scene where the only weapon they have
against these zombies is their records
their old records because this guy has a
humongous record collection so they're
sifting through their records and he's
like you want to throw this one I love
that one they put it back you want to
throw this one what's this one uh yeah
throw that one I don't like that one
they throw it and sticks into zombies
face you know like there's great scenes
like that where they don't take it too
seriously and I'm looking forward to
showing it to you we won't talk too much
more about Shaun of the Dead because I
haven't had a chance to show or tour yet
but it is a very fun film it's a very
creepy film and it's creepy in the best
type of way because you can have a
really entertaining time with it ladies
and gentlemen we now come to our final
film that we will be talking about yes
we didn't talk about The Exorcist and we
didn't talk about the omen and we didn't
talk about this and that and I apologize
but those films just simply aren't on
our list we're not saying they're bad
movies these are the type of films that
we like to watch this time of year this
last film is a film that you guys
generously submitted quite a bit of
footage for and I just want to say it
was pretty cool to sift through it
yeah I was actually really fun we got a
lot of a lot of good stuff the apologize
we couldn't get your submission in we
couldn't fit everything we got and we
got over to 300 submissions of stuff and
a lot of stuff a lot of it long so we
had to pick what we could and we
apologize if it is in there and I think
you're gonna like what we did make yeah
I hope you enjoy our cursed footage skit
it's actually my favorite skit that
we've done I saved the best for last
enjoy
is it
[Music]
so once again thanks very much for that
footage you guys did such a great job
and thanks to Eric Strickler from pretty
much it for submitting a shot that was
pretty cool he did his own version of
the Norman Bates psycho face go check
him out it pretty much it I really
appreciate that Eric thanks a lot the
ring is a movie that when I saw it in
2002 I was only 14 years old and it did
legitimately disturb me it had something
to do with the faces and it wasn't so
much what you actually saw on the screen
it was the thought because to me I was
starting to envision what happened
behind the scenes in this movie you see
in the opening of the movie you got
these two kids and they're watching a
tape and it seems very cliche like did
you hear about that tape oh my god like
what happened with the tape like oh man
like it seems like that cliche in horror
type film but they watch it her face
changes and it all goes wrong and then
later in the film the mother is talking
about how I saw my daughter's face and
then it just cuts to her in the closet
like with this light like look terrified
me when I was a kid and it wasn't just
the look it was the idea of a mother
coming home and finding your daughter
who had crawled in the closet after
being so terrified that her heart
stopped
and there's your daughter in the closet
and that's how she looks now and she's
dead
the thought of that just it's still
freaks me out okay I have to admit I
laughed at this film I really did I
couldn't make it through this film
without busting out with laughter it
made me laugh this is the one film in
our entire collection here that we do
not agree on and it's understandable
what was your environment when you saw
it where were you exactly who you with
I was with my sister and I was it
actually just my sister and we were at
home alone and there was a pulled
popcorn and I believe we had just sent
you Nina's pizza and so you actually
were in a good position for you just
didn't like it I know you disagree with
me on it and it's just a movie opinion
doesn't really matter it's just to me
when I saw it I view it also from the
eyes of a wannabe director gore
verbinski directed this movie who later
directed Pirates of the Caribbean his
vision for this movie was remarkable
it's lit and framed extremely well there
shot from this movie that I know are
extremely difficult to set up in certain
elements of CGI combined with real life
that was very impressive to me and it's
not just the tone and field of film that
gets under my skin it is a very well
directed movie no doubt it's not a
perfect on by any means it certainly has
flaws it's not considered like a classic
movie at all I just find it very creepy
and disturbing I will give it its credit
in the fact that it's actually really
well shot and I'll give I'll tell you
that it's very well done considering
what size jean Ernest usually you see
them and there's just so poorly edited
so poorly shot it would give it that it
was well done and what it was trying to
do and Naomi watch I thought did a great
job in the movie as well well guys that
is the end of our scary movie special we
both really appreciate you guys watching
don't we Rosie sorry guys we really
appreciate you watching it was really
nice we had a lot of fun talking about
poor films with you and we just want to
say from both of us thanks very much
we'd love to know we thought of our
skits and we hope you really enjoyed it
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck on it are you sure
you're alright hon it's just too much
late okay too much light okay um alright
well
[Music]
Oh God
yes my fiancee I don't know what's
happening she just stopped moving she's
not breathing I'm not sure what's going
on I'm not sure she just stopped
breathing we were seeing each other and
she just stopped breathing I'm not
entirely sure what happened but I was
right there with her she stopped
breathing she stopped moving
he got sent someone over as quickly as
possible I'm not sure if she's okay I
need you to help me out here
[Music]